[Musique]
une centaine de collégiens de l'hexagone
participant au championnat de france de
raid unss organisé à la réunion ont été
accueillis ce lundi 2 mai à mascara
jardin botanique à saint leu un rendez
vous avec la nature mise en place dans
ce patrimoine départemental renfermant
les espèces rares de notre île l'idée
c'est de sensibiliser les élèves les
collégiens qui arrivent des quatre coins
de la france sur la protection et la
préservation de la biodiversité
réunionnaise donc aujourd'hui nous
allons signer une charte une charte de
bonne conduite d'une charte du sportif
éco responsable c'est important parce
que le département s'est engagé
notamment pour faire la promotion du
sport de pleine nature donc aujourd'hui
c'est l'occasion de montrer qu'on est
présent et de montres et de valoriser
aussi nos espaces naturels sensibles
numéro 1 utilisera pour ta pratique les
espaces sites et itinéraires aménagé est
autorisée 2 tu ne jettera pas de déchets
dans la poubelle même les chefs-lieux
dégradable respecte son environnement tu
n'en porterai il appartient à la nature
bhl encore aux espèces protégées etc
c'est la première fois que la réunion
accueille ce championnat une destination
sélectionnés pour la richesse de sa
nature idéale pour la pratique sportive
en plein air la réunion c'était vraiment
l'endroit privilégié pour ces sportifs
et féru d'art carey a beaucoup
d'activités de travail qui sont
développées ici depuis de longues années
et que la manière dont
une essai c'est dur est donc activités
avec un mélange de vtt de présentation
de rating de passage dans les rivières
de d'activité très misto si c'est
vraiment le lieu à ne pas louper pour
sportifs pour des sportifs romands après
une séance de sensibilisation sur le
respect de l'environnement les jeunes
ont pu participer à la visite du jardin
botanique
guidés par les agents de mascara on a
souhaité leur faire découvrir toutes les
richesses de l'île au travers
différentes choses comme par exemple
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont arrivés ce
matin ont la chance de pouvoir venir au
jardin botanique et donc découvrir
toutes ces espèces qu'ils ne connaissent
pas mais sur lesquels ils sont très
sensibles parce que c'est des jeunes qui
ont l'habitude des sports de nature donc
ils sont ils ont cette sensibilité là et
je pense qu'ils vont être assez
émerveillé de venir ici et de découvrir
tout ça du côté des jeunes la plupart
découvrent la réunion pour la première
fois très excitée de découvrir l'île de
la réunion
ces merveilles et cetera
de faire leur aide bien évidemment et de
l'essayer pareil les activités
traditionnelles de l'île de la réunion
il ya beaucoup de verdure beaucoup de
variété ça nous de jouer un peu pour
faire en sorte que les activités comme
le raid de enfin les petits plaisirs de
la vie puisse se perd plus continuer je
suis heureuse d'être là chez
impatiente
de découvrir ce qu'on va faire si il n'y
a plus de plein air on peut plus faire
notre activité préférée il faut c'est
important pour notre futur et continuer
à vivre normalement après cette première
journée de découverte de la nature
réunionnaise les jeunes partent pour
trois jours d'aventuré d'épreuves
sportives au coeur de l'île intense
[Musique]